(audience applauding)
- Welcome back, everybody.
We've got Jane Fonda, Lily Tomlin,
and Sasheer Zamata with us.
(audience applauds and cheers)
It's a great day.
- We've been talking a lot
today about female friendships,
what makes a good friend,
and how important women are to each other.
We see that in every episode
of Jane and Lily's Netflix
show "Grace and Frankie."
Seriously, you gotta watch it.
Meanwhile, on Sasheer's
podcast with Nicole Byer,
she asked some important questions
about how far we go for a best friend,
like, you know, would you murder for me?
And that would be a hard pass. Nope.
So, it's time for a quick segment.
We are calling
"I'd do anything for friendship
but I won't do that."
♪ I would do anything for friendship ♪
♪ But I won't do that ♪
(Kelly laughs)
That's a new one. Nicely done.
Okay. So I'm gonna hit this button.
It's so expensive 'cause, yeah.
It's our super computer, and it will hack
into the national friendship
database, that totally exists,
to pull out another
tough test of friendship.
Then we're gonna all say,
if we would do that for
our best friend or not.
Here's where we find
out who we really are.
Here we go.
Okay.
(bell dings)
Would you...
Oh, hell no!
(all laughing)
Would you...
No.
Would you carry a baby for nine months
for your best friend?
No!
(audience laughing)
I didn't wanna carry mine.
(all laughing)
They were...
It was hell.
- Yeah.
- I don't know, but pregnancy is not cool.
It's not cool for some of us.
Would you do that?
- I love being pregnant,
- Dude.
- but at this point in life,
I would say to my best friend,
"Listen, my cells and hormones
and everything can barely
keep up with myself."
(Kelly laughs)
"I wouldn't be able to,
maybe if Kelly Clarkson sang
to my stomach everyday."
- [Kelly] Oh, my God.
- I haven't got the wherewithal
to carry my best friend's baby.
- I can't. What about you, Lily?
- But you should have had a baby.
- Lily, would you do that?
- No, no. It's all right.
No, I could have...
I've got a doll that like
makes me think it's a baby.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- You got one of those?
- Yeah.
- And that doesn't sound creepy at all.
(Lily and Kelly laughs)
(audience applauding)
Good thing.
Wait, let's do another one.
(bell dings)
Okay. Would you lie to
Congress for your best friend?
Hell no.
- No. I might lie for my worst friend.
(all laughing)
(audience applauding)
- That's awesome. What a great answer.
Jane, what about you? (laughs)
- Yeah. I like her answer.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- How about you?
- I mean, they lie to us.
(audience cheering and applauding)
I feel like I can reciprocate. (chuckles)
- I feel like I do one.
- [Sasheer] Yeah.
I can lie a little bit.
- I would not.
I don't lie, and I do not keep secrets.
Don't tell me.
I hate secrets.
They weigh on me like more
weight that I don't need.
So here we go.
Another one.
(bell dings)
If you caught your friend's spouse, ooh,
if you caught your
friend's spouse cheating,
would you tell her?
Now, I've done this.
I've told my friend, and
it didn't work out for me.
- Oh.
- Yeah.
But, didn't end up working
out for her either.
But, like...
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- But it-
- Was it like
a mind your business kind of thing?
- It was just like I don't
think I was believed.
I don't think they believed me.
And it was one of those-
- Go and message her.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. And I was like,
you know what?
It's worth it though,
because I would want to know.
I would want someone
to tell me.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause if you ever been that fool...
I've been that fool, too,
- Aw.
- that didn't know.
Have you been that fool?
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah. That sucks.
- Yeah.
- So that's why I would
tell. Would you tell?
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I would introduce you to each other.
- I would introduce to talk about it.
(Kelly laughs and applauds)
- No, because...
(audience applauding)
(Kelly laughs)
- No, if you were both
suffering, I would just...
That might give you a clue.
If I said, "Hey, you know,
you need to meet Kelly,
and Kelly should meet you."
- And then I'll just start talking, yep.
- [Sasheer] "You have a lot in common."
- You're sneaky.
- Let them figure it out.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah. You're like a sneaky helpful.
- Yeah.
- That was nice.
I like that, sneaky helpful.
Okay. Okay. What would you do?
Would you tell?
- I would 100% tell.
I would tell if I just saw him out.
(Kelly laughs)
Just like,
"He was at the grocery
store, did you know?"
(Lily laughs)
- Would you say alone?
(all laughing)
Driving home.
- Yeah.
- "He was alone."
- "He was alone, getting
hotdogs by himself."
(all laughing)
- [Lily] Good answer.
- Oh, my God. It's a solid answer.
Thank you ladies so much.
We learned a lot here, people.
(audience cheering and applauding)